[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الرابعه من الرياض والتي نقدم من
خلالها ابرز اخبار وملفات السعوديه
والخليج وهذه ابرز عناوين اليوم
مجموعه العمل الخليجيه الامريكيه تطالب
ايران بوقف استفزازاتها النوويه وتدين
ممارساتها في المنطقه
تنتشر فتاه من تحت الانقاض في ولايه
قهرمان مرعش بعد 248 ساعه من الزلزال
تركي
رئيس فريق التدخل السريع بمركز الملك
سلمان يكشف للعربيه عن وصول خمسه الاف
خيمه لايواء متضرر الزلزال
الرابع ايضا
ولي العهد السعودي يطلق شركه المربع
الجديد لتطوير اكبر داون تاون حديث عالميا
في الرياض
الفريق الطبي بمدينه الملك عبد العزيز
بالرياض ينتهي من عمليه فصل توام السيامي
اليمني
حياكم الله ادان البيان المشترك الاجتماعي
مجموعه العمل الخليجيه الامريكيه المشتركه
الخاصه بايران سياسات طهران المستمره في
زعزعه استقرار المنطقه والعالم بما في ذلك
دعمها للارهاب عبر نشرها الصواريخ
المتقدمه وانظمه الطائرات دون الطيار عبر
البيان عن مخاوفه من استمرار طهران في
تزويد الحوثيين بالاسلحه الامر الذي يشكل
تهديدا امنيا خطيرا وفيما يخص البرنامج
النووي الايراني دعى البيان المشترك طهران
الى وقف ما وصفه بالاستفزازات النوويه
التي تجاوزت الاحتياجات المدنيه للبلاد
وعليه حتت مجموعه العمل الخليجيه
الامريكيه ايران على التعاون مع تحقيقات
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه خاصه تلك
التي عثر عليها في مواقع غير معلنه
[موسيقى]
اخرجت فرق الانقاذ فتاه تبلغ من العمر 17
عاما من تحت انقاض مبنى انهار في قهرمان
مرعش جنوب وسط تركيا وذلك بعد 248 ساعه من
وقوع الزلزال ونقلت مقاطع مصوره نقل
الفتاه عبر محبه الى سياره اسعاف ونقلها
الى المستشفى
[موسيقى]
وصف الامين العام لحلف الناتو ينسى زلزاله
تركيا وسوريا بانه اكبر الكوارث المميته
والمروعه في اراضي حلف الناتو منذ تاسيسه
وقال في مؤتمر الصحفي مع وزير الخارجيه
التركي مولود اوكلو في انقره ان دول الحلف
تعمل على مدار الساعه لنقل المساعدات الى
تركيا
رصد موفد العربيه احد طرق المدمره بفعل
الزلازل في محيط مدينه غازي عنتاب ويظهر
حجم قوه الزلزال الذي ادى الى تكسير شارع
فرعي وتسبب في تشققات عميقه
تابعنا طيله الايام الماضيه اثر الزلزال
الكارثي الذي ضرب العديد من المدن جنوب
تركيا سنشاهد معهد الان احد اثار هذا
الزلزال كما تشاهدون هذا الشارع تغيرت
معالمه بالكامل وكما تشاهدون قوه الزلزال
كيف اثرت على هذا الشارع وهذه وهذا الدمار
الكبير الذي لحق بهذا الشارع في مدينه
غازي عنتاب يعني يمكن ان تشاهده حجم
الدمار الكبير الذي ادى الى هذه التشققات
وهذه الصدوع الكبيره
يعني الارض واضح انها يعني بشكل كبير
تاثرت تتحدث السلطان السلطات وخبراء
الزلازل ايضا عن يعني ازاحه للقشره
الارضيه بمسافه تقدر باكثر من سبعه امتار
ولكم ان تشاهدوا هذا المشهد في غازي عنتاب
غسان ابو اللوز العربيه
غازي عنتاب
ووصل الثالث طائرات لغتله السعوديه الى
مطار حلب الدولي والتي تحمل على متنها
مساعدات عاجله لضحايا الزلزال في سوريا
منها مواد غذائيه وايوائيه وطبيبيه متنوعه
الطائرات الاغاثيه السعوديه التي اعلن
عنها مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال
الانسانيه جاءت ضمن جسر جوي لمساعده
المتضررين في سوريا وتركيا بشكل عاجل
كشفاء فهد العصيمي رئيس فريق التدخل
السريع في الحمله الاغاثيه لمركز الملك
سلمان عن وصول نحو خمسه الاف خيمه الى
سوريا وتركيا لمساعده ضحايا الزلزال
احنا اليوم تقريبا احنا سنه ما يعادل 3000
قيمه الى الجانب التركي واحد تقريبا 2000
خيمه الى جانب سوري حتى هذا التاريخ لاننا
المساعدات سوف تستمر هناك فريق تطوعي
ساعدنا اليوم فوق مساعده الجانب التركي في
بناء هذه المخيم السريع الى المحتاجين في
في نقطه الزلزال
اليوم تقريبا عندنا اكثر من 12 او 13
متطور قاموا وللحمد مساعده اخوانهم
المتضررين سوف تكون هناك انتقال من نقطه
الى نقطه تقريبا اليوم
وحنساعد في بناء اكثر من يمكن خمسين الى
200 الى الى 100 خيمه باذن الله
ومنها طاي ينضم الينا موفد العربيه عمار
الهندي عمار مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في
نشره الرابعه من الرياض لا تزال ربما فرق
البحث ايضا
والتقصي والانقاذ يعني على قدم وساق عملها
حتى هذه اللحظه كيف يمكن وصف الصوره من
حولك عمار هذا صحيح هذا صحيح نحن امام
مبنى استخرجت منه للتو عدد من الجثانيين
طبعا الذين يعملون هنا
متطوعون سوريون لان اغلب العائلات هنا في
هذه المباني السوريه
وبالتالي يعني اخرجوا من هذا المبنى عدد
من الجثامين تعرف طبعا الاسر التي تعود
اليها هذه الجيتمين تعرفت اليها في هذه
الاكياس السوداء وهذه الاكياس التي تظهر
امامك هذه الجثامين طبعا من بينها جثمان
لطفل صغير وضعت في هذه الاكياس كما قلت لك
يعني كما قلت وشرحت من قبل
سيارتنا معنا جزاه الله خير انا علمت انه
انتم يعني انتم جبتوا لهذا المبنى لانه في
عدد كبير من الجثثيمين الفاتح خرجنا حوالي
30 شخص ويوم الاثنين مضى بعد 8 ايام
طالعنا امراه عايشه بفضل الله عز وجل هذا
التوفيق يوم كم جثتي طلعته لحد هاي اللحظه
نعم ولكن الله يرحمهم طيب قديش عندكم
معلومات تبقى عدد من الجثث داخل المبنى
هذا
اقل شيء اقل شيء هذا المبنى مبارح نحن
صرنا يومين بهاي المنطقه هون لكن قبل كنا
عند جامع فاتح عن جامع فاتح
بينهم من بين هذه الجثمين طفل صح انا
شاهدته
اشخاص هون ثلاث وفي ثلاث اطفال مبينهم
طفلين طفلين نعم الله يرحمه اللهم امين في
حدا بيساعدكم بعطيكم دعم يعني انتم
معداتكم دعم معداتنا البساطه المهدي ما في
دعم اي دعم النحل سجلنا حبينا نكون مع
فريق يكون اقوى هاي كيكون اسهل لنا بالشغل
لكن ما حدا رد لنا خبر الحمد لله نحن عنا
خبره من ايام سوريا يعني
توفيق من الله توكلنا على الله نعم ونعم
بالله ونعم بالله طيب بدي اسالك سؤال
الفرق الانقاذ انا شفتها على الساعه سته
تتوقف سته مساء انتم بتتوقفوا ولا شو لو
كان في جهد ليل ونهار نحن نستمر هذه ارواح
ما في شيء اغلى من الارواح نعم ستستمرون
ليل ونهار والله اقسم بالله مستعد ليه
اخرج اي نفس
التي تعرف اليها وتعرف على هذه الجثانين
يعني
الله يرحمها افراد اسره
اسرته وفعلا يعني الشباب تعمل موقف بشكل
متطوع لساعات طويله ومستمره بادوات بسيطه
جدا يعني يسابقون الزمن لانه خشيت انتشار
الامراض طبعا انا اتحدث اليك وللاسف
الشديد انه رائحه الموت في كل مكان نعم
طيب عمار ايضا في في في مناطق
في مناطق اخرى ايضا في في هاتاي تم
استخراج يعني او دعنا نقول يعني عمليات
بحث
واخراج ناجين ايضا كذلك من تحت الانقاض
استمرت لحوالي تقريبا 280 ساعه من بعد
الزلزال خلال هذه الفتره ما الذي رصدت انت
من مشاهدات اخراج الناجين عمار
نعم اعتقد في قهرمان مرعش كان كانت هنالك
اخراج لسيده بعد 248 ساعه ولكن في هاتاي
للاسف الشديد يعني الامل الامل شبه مقطوع
يعني ربما وصلوا الناس الى امل الى السفر
من مستوى الصفر من الامل لانه نحن في
اليوم 11 وبالتالي كل العمليات تتركز على
اخراج الجثامين والمفقودين لانه جل ما
يشغل
بالناس هنا سواء اتراك او سوريين مهما كان
الشخص هو اخراج الجثمين من تحت الانقاض
ودفنها انا اليوم كنت في مكان فيه جثه
يعني ظاهره من تحت الانقاض وللاسف لم
تنتشر حتى هذه اللحظه ووجدت شخص يقف الى
جانب هذه هذه البنايه وسالته يعني الشارع
فارغ من الناس سالت ماذا تفعل قال لي انا
اتواجد هنا لان هنالك جثه تحت الانقاض
اراقبها حتى لا تضيع وانتظر فرق الانقاذ
تاتي وترفع هذه الجثه لدفنها هذا المشهد
بحد ذاته مؤلم جدا يعني مؤلم مؤلم
وبالتالي هنالك مشكله بانه اساسا فرق
الانقاذ خلال يعني اخر ثلاث ايام واليوم
تتوقف في معظمها عن العمل الساعه السادسه
مساء منها بعض عددها قليل تتوقف الساعه
التاسعه ولكن الشبان المتطوعين يعملون
يعني على مدار الساعه صراحه وهذا هذا مثال
يعني كنا نستمع للشاب يعني هم الان اخرجوا
جثه يعني شوف شفت الان يعني يبدو انهم
اخرجوا جثه نعم هذه جثه على الاغلب ولكن
الجثث كثيره
نايف في كل مكان للاسف الشديد ويبدو انها
جثه الطفل هذا طفل
للاسف هذه جثه طفل اخرجت للتو من تحت
الانقاذ نايف يعني المشهد مرعب ومحزن جدا
رحمه الله عليهم
اسئله كثيره جميعا رحمه الله عليهم جميعا
ولكن هذا المشهد على الارض في المناطق
المنكوبه في اليوم ال11 لهذا الزلزال
المدمر في انطاكيا في هاتاي اشكرك جزيل
الشكر زميل العمار الهندي منفذ العربيه من
منطقه
نعود مره اخرى للحديث عن البيان المشترك
لاجتماع مجموعه العمل الخليجيه الامريكيه
المشتركه الخاصه بايران وينضموا الي من
المنامه الكاتبه السياسي عبد الله الجنيد
سيد عبدالله مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في
نشره الرابعه من الرياض اولا كيف تقرا هذا
البيان لمجموعه العمل الخليجيه الامريكيه
ما الجديد الذي حمله ايضا في تقديرك اسال
الله مسائك وكذلك مشاهدي العربيه وبرنامج
رابع هل هو اتى بجديد نتمنى ان ياتي بجديد
ولكن الترجمه الفعليه لعمليه احتواء
ممارسات ايران على المستويات الاقليمي او
الملفات الاخرى من ضمنها الملف النووي يجب
ان تترجم في قرارات واضحه من الحليف
الامريكي وان اراد ذلك الحديث
ترجمه فعليه حقيقيه وليكن ذلك في اليمن ما
نحتاجه هو ابراز مساحه
للتوافقات الاستراتيجيه واهمها الان ان
ارد ايصال رساله واضحه لايران فيجب ان
تكون من خلال ملف
اليمني وليس غير ذلك
البيان ايضا في موضوع اليمن اكد استمرار
ايران في تزويد الحوثينه بالاسلحه
التقليديه الصواريخ المتقدمه انظمه
الطائرات بدون طيار
وكذلك قال بان هذا سيطيل امد الصراع في
اليمن يؤدي ايضا كذلك الى تفاقم الكارثه
الانسانيه لكن لماذا تمد ايران الحوثين
بهذه الاسلحه صواريخ النوعيه المتقدمه
يعني في ظل على الاقل هدوء الامور نسبيا
حتى هذه اللحظه لا نتحدث طبعا عن هدنه
يعني لم لم يتم
تجديدها مره اخرى فبتقديرك ماذا تؤشر يعني
هذه الجزئيه في البيان
الملف اليمني يحتاج الى اكثر من
نظره
والمساءله كذلك
خطوط ايصال مثل هذه الاسلحه النوعيه الى
اليمن كيف وعبر من وان كانت هناك تغطيه من
اطراف دوليه فيجب ان تسالوا بشكل صريح
ثانيا ما هو موقف المجلس الرئاسي وما هي
الخطوات الفعليه على ارض الواقع التي تعزز
من جهود
التحالف الدولي وخصوصا
المملكه العربيه السعوديه والامارات
تحديدا ثالثا كيف تفهم الولايات المتحده
ضرورات ومخاطر السلامه هذه الازمه على امن
واستقرار هذه المنطقه نحن من يتضرر ونحن
من يدفع ثمن ذلك على الولايات المتحده ان
كانت جاده اولا يجب ان تعود صياغه بعض
مواقفها وخصوصا لليمن
وتحديدا منظرها هي
الحوثيين من منظور
المظلوميه الشيعيه التاريخيه لا توجد
شيعيه في خصوصا في اليمن ثانيا ما تقوم ما
يقوم به الحوثيين لا يمثل كافه
الشيعه اليمنيين
ثالثا
استدامه هذه الازمه يعذر يعني يعمق من
مستوى المعاناه الانسانيه وهذا ما ذكره
البيان ولكن
[موسيقى]
اعذرني يعني ليس لديك الكثير من الوقت لكن
الحديث كذلك عن البرنامج النووي الايراني
على ذكر هذا البيان
قيل هنا طبعا عن اعراب الولايات المتحده
عن التزامها بتوسيع النطاق الدفاعي كذلك
اكدت التزام الرئيس بايدن بعدم السماح
بامتلاك سلاح نووي لكن هذا البيان كرر
التاكيد على ان الدبلوماسيه هي الاسلوب
المفضل لمعالجه سياسات ايران المزعزع
للاستقرار وتصعيدها النووي هل تعتقد انه
لا زال هنا مجال للدبلوماسيه ان
الدبلوماسيه لا زالت يعني قويه وهي
الاسلوب المفضل ربما او الاسلوب الافضل في
التعامل مع الواقع ايران اليوم بعد ان
وصلت الى مراحل متقدمه في تقسيط
اليورانيوم
يا سيدي التخصيب هي واحده من الاليات وليس
كل الاليات هناك اخطار اكبر في البرنامج
النووي الايراني وهو سلامه او سلامه
النوويه لو تم هناك وبالذات مفاعل بو شهر
متقادم جدا ويعاني من الكثير من المشاكل
الفنيه ففي حال تسرب او حدوث حادث نووي في
هذا المفاعل فسوف تكون مضاره اكبر من اي
منه اصول ايران لامتلاك سلاح نووي ان كانت
الولايات المتحده جاده في هذا الموضوع
يعني لننظر الان مجموعه العمل الخليجيه
الامريكيه
للتو أصلت بيانها وفي نفس التوقيت ايران
تعلن ان المحادثات المباشره مع الولايات
المتحده حول هذا الملف باتت مثمره اي ما
هي اشارات التي تحاول الولايات المتحده
تقديمها لع الخليجيين اشكرك جزيل الشكر من
المنامه انضم الينا الكاتب السياسي عبد
الله الجنيد حياك الله
السبعه وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيه دي مترو
كوليبا اقصاء روسيا من مجلس الامن في
الرابع والعشرين من فبراير الحالي وخلال
لقاء مع وسائل الاعلام العربيه التامه
روسيا باحتلال مقاعد الاتحاد السوفيتي في
المجلس
يجب ان نكون واقعيين فمساله طرد روسيا من
مجلس الامن لن تتم في الرابع والعشرين من
فبراير انها عمليه طويله في الحياه لا
يمكن ان يحدث شيء بسرعه هدفنا الان هو عرض
قصتنا وكيف احتلت روسيا مقعد الاتحاد
السوفيتي في مجلس الامن التابع للامم
المتحده
الرابعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
ولي العهد السعودي يطلق شركه المربع
الجديد لتطوير اكبر داون تاون حديث عالميا
في الرياض
حياكم الله من جديد
اعلن ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان عن اطلاق شركه تطوير المربع الجديد
بهدفي تطوير اكبر داون تاون حديث عالميا
في الرياض مشروع المربع الجديد سيعتمد في
تصاميمه على تطبيق معايير الاستدامه ورفع
جوده الحياه كما سيتم اقامه المشروع على
مساحه تتجاوز 19 كيلو مترا مربعا وبمساحه
طابقيه تصل لاكثر من 25 مليون متر مربع
المشروع الجديد سيوفر اكثر من 100 الف
وحده سكنيه بطاقه استيعابيه لمئات الاف
السكان وكذلك متحفا مبتكرا وجامعه متخصصه
في التقنيه والتصميم
[موسيقى]
من مدينه لاهاي الهولنديه ينضم الينا
المخطط الحضري فؤاد عسيري سيد فؤاد مساء
الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشاط الرابعه من
الرياض
المشروع أب اليوم اريد ان اسالك عن
الاضافه التي سيضيفها هذا المشروع والفرق
بينه وبين تطوير مناطق تاريخيه اخرى مثل
مشروع بوابه الدرعيه مثلا ما الذي يختلف
عن هذا المشروع
والله طلعنا على مشروع اللي اطلق سمو ولي
العهد اليوم في الواقع ان هذا المشروع من
وجهه نظري انا انه مشروع تكنولوجي عمراني
اكثر من كونه مشروع عمراني والسبب بسيط
جدا وواضح ان هذا المشروع بكون انه يستخدم
التكنولوجيا العاديه العاليه التقنيات
العاليه جدا الا انها ايضا ينتج
التكنولوجيا والدليل ان وجود جامعه متخصصه
للتكنولوجيا والتصميم هذا اهم فرق عن بقيه
المشاريع التطوير
العمرانيات اللي ممكن نتخيلها موجوده في
هذا المشروع سيد فؤاد هو في تقنيات
الهولوجرام باسلوب
متطور جدا وهو الاستخدام هو الذي سيتيح
للزائر التعرف على بيئات جديده مختلفه
ومتنوعه اكثر من المشاريع العمرانيه
المشاريع العمرانيه التقليديه هي محدوده
بالطابع الموجود الطراز الموجود والطابع
الموجود لكن المشروع هذا داخل
المكعب سوف يكون
البيئات اللي الذي سوف يعرضها المكعب مئات
مختلفه ومتنوعه ولا باستخدام التقنيات
الحديثه مثل
وبالتالي من النظره الاولى للفيديو لهذا
المشروع يشبه كثيرا يعني استشراف المستقبل
مثل دلاين في في اعلان دلاين الاول ان كنت
شاهدت العام الماضي يعني اكيد انت شفته
طبعا
اريد ان اسال يعني المشاريع بهكذا شكل
بهكذا تخيل
المستقبل ايضا القادم ما الذي تعنيه
بالنسبه للمدينه بالنسبه للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه ايضا حتى كذلك فيما يخص التخطيط
الحضري والتصميم العمراني والتراثي ايضا
في هذه المنطقه
بالنسبه لي انا هذا بانني انني اجلبها
واستحضر المستقبل الي الان بدل ان انتظر
المستقبل ان يفاجئني باشياء انا لم اكن
مستعد لها
طيب خلينا نروح نشوف ايضا نتوقف فقط مع
هذه
مع هذا الفيديو
لشكل طبعا هذا الشكل المكعب طبعا بهذا
المشروع ثم اعود اليك
المكعب
[موسيقى]
اعود الى ضيفي السيد فؤاد مره اخرى
طبعا الشكل المكعب هنا ربما يشبه الطراز
النجده القديم في التصميم اريد ان اسال عن
دلاله هذا الشكل انت كمخطط حضري وعمراني
ويعني مهتم ايضا بهذا القطاع كيف تنظر
اليه لماذا هذا الشكل وما الذي يميزه كذلك
والله هو استحضار لفكره الطراز النجدي مثل
ما تفضلت اللي هي معظم المنازل او القصور
في ذلك الوقت كانت مكعبه تحضر مثلا
الايقونه بقصر الملك عبد العزيز اللي هو
المربع من الخارج تجده قصر بسيط بالوان
بسيطه بنوافذ صغيره ولكنك لما تدخل جوا
وسيعه تجد اروقه بيضات تجد مجالس وسيعه اي
ان البيئه الداخليه مختلفه تماما عن
المشهد الخارجي وهذا مرمز بشكل ممتاز في
المكعب حيث ان من الخارج يبدو سري مبنى
سري لا تتوقع ماذا يحدث ماذا قد تجد
بالداخل ولكن بالداخل ستجد معالم وبيئات
مختلفه كثيره ومتنوعه يمكن قد تكون لا
محدوده فهو استحضار من التراث لكن بشكل
جديد طبعا فكره المكعب هي
تطوير لفكره منطقه الارتكاز الرئيسيه في
اي تطوير العمراني ان كان ساحه او سوق او
مجمع تجاري او خلافه ولكن هنا نقطه
الارتكاز حتكون هي المكعب
بما مع المشروع مع بقيه اطراف المشروع
اللي هي البيئه العمرانيه المحيطه
شكرا من مدينه لهاي الهولنديه المخطط
الحضري فؤاد عسير شكرا جزيلا لك
الوجهه
اذا قبل قليل لاكون ان نشاهد واياكم اخبار
العاجله الصوت
يقول بان على حلف الناتو ان يكون مستعدا
لازمه طويله المدى مع روسيا قبل قليل اسفل
الخبر وصفه للشاشه في شريط الاخبار
العاجله عوده الى الرابعه وفي العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض انتهت عمليه فصل التوام
السيامي اليمني سلمان وعبد الله وعمرهما
اربعه اشهر وذلك في مستشفى الملك عبد الله
التخصصي للاطفال بمدينه الملك عبد العزيز
الطبيه هذا وشارك في العمليه خمسه وثلاثون
طبيبا وكادرا فنيا
وطبيا كما تم اجراء العمليه على سبع مراحل
من مستشفى الملك عبدالله التخصصي بوزاره
الحرس الوطني انضم الينا مراسل العربيه
نواف عزيز نواف مساء الخير يعطيك العافيه
يا نواف انت موجود ومواكب لهذه العمليه
منذ الصباح بمراحلها السبع نريد ان تجمل
وتلخص لنا ما الذي حدث منذ الصباح حتى
الان في هذه العمليه وهي انتهت طبعا قبل
ساعات
بالتاكيد نايف قبل دقائق وصل التوام
السيامي اليمني سلمان وعبد الله الى قسم
التنويم في العنايه المركزه قبل دقائق فقط
انتقلوا من غرفه العمليات الى هذا القسم
بعد نجاح العمليه نشاهد من خلفي الان
التوام
يتواجد في هذه الغرفه بجانبه ايضا
الطفل الاخر بحضور من العائله وبتواجد
ايضا من الدكتور عبد الله الربيعه قائد
الفريق الطبي اذا كان الدكتور يستطيع
التحدث معنا وهو يشرف على حاله التوام
السيامي بعد الانتقال الى العنايه المركزه
اهلا وسهلا دكتور ماذا بعد العمليه كم
سيبقى الطفلين في
القسم التنوين بالعنايه المركزه وكيف
ستتابعون ذلك اولا مرحبا بكم بمشاهدين
الكرام
العربيه والحمد لله رب العالمين ان هذه
العمليه تكللت بالنجاح وفي وقت قياسي
واشكر من دعم وتابع ووجه بهذا العمليه
خادم الحرم الشريفين وولي عهد الامين حفظه
الله كذلك اشكر زملائي وزميلاتي اعضاء
الفريق الطبي 35 من الاستشاريين
والاخصائيين والكوادر التمريضيه والفنيه
تعمل معنا ووجه لهم كلمه شكر وتقدير طبعا
العمليه كما شاهدتم وتسمعون سياح سلمان
خلفي ونفس الشيء عبد الله هنالك انجاز اخر
انه من النادر ان نستطيع رفع الانابيب
وافاقه الاطفال في التوائم السياميه الحمد
لله اليوم هذا انجاز اخر ان سلمان افاق
بعد اكتمال العمليه وعبد الله افاق بعد
اكتمال العمليه والان هو ربما يطلب بعض
المهدئات من الالم او الرضاعه بالنسبه
العنايه المركزه سوف يبكون في العلم
المركزه قرابه ثلاث اربع ايام واذا كانت
حلمتهم مستقره سوف يتم نقلهم لجناح
الاطفال وبدء الرضاعه الطبيعيه وبدء مرحله
التاهيل كلا التوام يحتاجان الى عمليه
تجميليه لاحقه في الجهاز التناسلي ولكنها
عمليات صغيره جدا تجرى بشكل عادي في كل
يوم انا بس اسجل ان المملكه العربيه
السعوديه اليوم ترسم صوره مشرقه عن العمل
الانساني العمل الانساني الكبير نشاهده ما
قدمت المملكه
للدول واخرها كان اثر الزلزال في كل من
سوريا وتركيا واليوم كذلك عمل انساني اخر
وهو عمل طبي نبيل
المملكه الى اليوم ساعدت اكثر من 23 دوله
في البرنامج السعودي لفصل توائم السياميه
55 فصل للتوائم بنجاح لليمن ثمان حالات
اليوم هذه هي الثامنه بالنسبه لسلمان وعبد
الله من محافظه الجوف ولكن اذا نظرنا
لبقيه التوائم ياتون من جميع المحافظات
صعد الصنعه تعز عدن وحضرموت وهذا يؤكد ان
العمل الانساني السعودي عمل شفاف عمل
محايد لا يرتبط باي اجنده لا يرتبط
بحدود جغرافيه سياسيه عسكريه انما هدف
المملكه العربيه السعوديه رفع معاناه
الانسان اينما كان نعم الدكتور مجريات
العمليه لاحظنا ان العمليه مرت بساعات اقل
من المعتاد في العمليات الاخرى لفصل
التوام كيف كانت المجريات هل كانت العمليه
سهله لم تواجه صعوبات كل عمليه فيها
تحدياتها وصعوباتها لكن يجب ان يعلم
الجميع ان هنالك فريق طبي لديه خبره تزيد
عن
سنه هذا الفريق الطبي اللي مهما شكرتهم
انا اكون مقصر وهذه الخبره
تعكس كيفيه التعامل مع التحديات والصعوبات
مثل ما حدث اليوم هنالك تحديات اشتراك في
الامعاء في المثانه البوليه بين الامعاء
والمثانه البوليه في الجهاز التناسلي ولكن
استطاع الفريق ان يتعامل معها ويقصر وقت
العمليه والتوام يفيق وهو في غرفه
العمليات انا اعتقد هذا ليس سهوله عمليه
وانها خبره فريق خبره وطن ودعم من القياده
للانسان كل الشكر لك الدكتور عبد الله
الربيعه قائد الفريق الطبي الذي اجرى
عمليه فصل التوام السيامي اليمني كما ذكر
الدكتور عبد الله نايف بان هناك متابعه
مستمره عمليات تجميل وان كانت بسيطه ولكن
هناك متابعه مستمره لحاله التوام السيامي
اليمني سلمان
عبد الله الحمد لله على سلامتهم شكرا
جزيلا لك ولضيفك الكريم من مستشفى الملك
عبد الله التخصصي بوزاره الحرس الوطني
مراسل العربيه
امل اخر ضحايا الالغام الحوتيه تروي قصه
انفجار لغم تسبب في فقدان عينهم وبدء
معاناه من نوع اخر نشاهد
انا امل عروس لم يترك لها الحوثيون من
اسمها شيئا بعد انفجار لغم زرعه الحوثي
لتنضم بذلك الى سلسله الضحايا المدنيين
[موسيقى]
الناس كله وبعدين رحتوا شاخدوا عليهم
علشان ما يتعوروش في واحد منهم قفز شي
خذوا من يدي للارض وانفجر وبعد المستشفى
استاذ
الجوامع ولو ما اخذوهاش هم يعني اكيد
بتروحوا ضحيتي اطفال كثير ناس كثير
فقدان عيني امل كان البدايه لمعاناه من
نوع اخر اثر هذا الانفجار بتعامل مع الناس
مثلا
ضروري تخاف يعني
[موسيقى]
كنت بالبدايه لا تنمرات من
يعني داخل الجامعه داخل القاعه بالشارع
يعني الاسئله اللي كانت توجه لي يعني صعبه
جدا وبعدين لما يعني كده كنت احيانا خلاص
[موسيقى]
اعلنت منصه اسامه التابعه لمركز الملك
سلمان لغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه عن مجموعه
تبرعات لمساعده متضرر الزلزال في سوريا
وتركيا والتي تجاوزت 360 مليون ريال تبرع
بها اكثر من مليون و600 الف شخص من مختلف
مناطق السعوديه
استفدت اكثر من مليونين ومئتين الف حول
العالم من الاشخاص الاكثر احتياجا وفي
اكثر المناطق المنكوبه استفادوا من برامجه
ومشاريع رابطه العالم الصحيه التي تنوعت
بين برامج العمليات الجراحيه والمشاريع
كالمستشفيات والمراكز الصحيه وغيرهم خلال
الفتره من العام 2016 وحتى نهايه 2022
نشاهد
في اكثر مناطق الاحتياج حول العالم كان
لرابطه العالم الاسلامي دور مهم في حياه
الملايين من الاشخاص الاشد فقرا ومن ضحايا
الكوارث والنزاعات عبر برامجها المتنوعه
والتي من ابرزها برامج الرعايه الصحيه
المقدمه للمرضى في عشرات الدول دون النظر
في عرقهم او دينهم فخلال سبعه اعوام وبين
العام 2016 وحتى نهايه العام 2022
استفاد من برامج الرابطه للرعايه الصحيه
اكثر من مليونين ومئتي الف شخص حول العالم
حيث نفذت 26 مشروعا تنوعت بين المستشفيات
والمراكز الطبيه المتخصصه والصيدليات
وغيرها في 16 دوله قدمت عبرها كافه
الخدمات الطبيه لاكثر من مليوني مريض في
هذه المناطق فيما وصلت برامجها التي بلغ
عددها 111 برنامجا لاكثر القرى النائيه
بعدا في 26 دوله حول العالم نفذت عبرها
نحو 34 الف عمليه جراحيه منها عمليات
قسطره القلب والعيون وغيرها لتغير بها
حياه مئات الاف المرضى
كما عملت الرابطه على تحقيق اهدافها
الصحيه عبر كافه الطرق حيث وفرت برنامج
المساعدات العلاجيه للمحتاجين بتحمل جزء
او كل التكاليف العلاجيه في دول مختلفه
اضافه الى عقدها شراكات استراتيجيه مع
منظمات انسانيه دوليه ومنها منظمه الصحه
العالميه واللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
للمساهمه في تحقيق العداله الصحيه عالميا
ومعالجه اجساد انهكها الفقر واخرى دمرتها
الحروب والكوارث
الرابعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل ايضا
كاوست تحتضن اول مخيم للتدريب الفضائي في
السعوديه بمشاركه مئتي طالب وطالب
حياكم الله من جديد اطلقت جامعه الملك عبد
الله للعلوم والتقنيه مخيم الفضاء
2201 الذي يحظى باعتراف عالمي ويعتبر
الاول من نوعه في السعوديه يهدف المخيم
مشاهدينا لخلق نافذه من الفرص للشباب
السعودي من خلال التبني المبكر للمواهب في
مجالات العلوم والتقنيه والهندسه والفنون
والرياضيات وذلك بمشاركه الهيئه السعوديه
للفضاء ووكاله ناسا
تقضي هذه الطالبه ساعات طويله خلف شاشه
الكمبيوتر لتصميم حياه افتراضيه على كوكب
المريخ حلم يراود لنا النابلسي احدى
المشاركات في مخيم الفضاء التدريبي بجامعه
كاوست والذي تنظمه الهيئه السعوديه للفضاء
بالشراكه مع وكاله ناسا الامريكيه عمري
سبع سنين وانا كنت منراحه بالفضاء وكان
عندي فضول واجد عنهم الفرصه جتني اللي هي
كانت حقه كاوست فعلى طول اخذت الفرصه
الحمد لله والحمد لله دخلت ومره استفدت
منها الحمد لله
ومره كانت تجربه جميله واشوف نفسي
بالمستقبل ان شاء الله مهندسه فضاء ان شاء
الله الفضاء مو كلهم اكتشف وعندي فضول اني
اكتشف زياده عنه فيمكن هذا اللي خلاني مره
مره احبه وخصوصا الث
العلميه والتكنولوجيه لدينا تقريبا 100
طالب وطالبه وهذا العدد من المؤكد انه
سيتضاعف مستقبلا يعد مخيم الفضاء التدريبي
الاول من نوعه في السعوديه
ويهدف لخلق نافذه من الفرص للشباب السعودي
من خلال التبني المبكر للمواهب في مجالات
العلوم والتقنيه والهندسه والفنون وعلم
الفلك والفضاء من جامعه الملك عبد الله
للعلوم التقنيه سلطان السلمي العربيه
الشمس وصلت هذه الفتره الى منتصف المسافه
بين مدار الجدي وخط الاستواء التفاصيل في
تقويم
[موسيقى]
للشمس مسارات متغيره ولهذا مكان وزمان
شروق وغروب الشمس يختلف بشكل يومي ومسارها
يختلف بشكل فصلي فمسارها في الشتاء اقصر
من الصيف ولهذا اطول نهر السنه في عز
القير واطول ليالي السنه في عز الشتاء
والشمس الان وصلت منتصف المسافه بين مدار
الجدي وخط الاستواء وبعد شهر تقريبا 16
مارس ستصل الى خط الاستواء وحين ذاك
يتساوى فيه طول الليل مع النهار دع دموعي
تسيل سيلا بدارا وضلوعي يصلين بالودي نارا
قد اعاد الاسى نهاريه ليلا منذ اعاد
المشيب لي
نهارا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وهل الاولين الله يرحمهم ويعرفون تساوي
الليل مع النهار من مكان شروره وغروب
الشمس فاذا اشرقت الشمس من المشرق تماما
وغربت من المغرب تماما قالوا هذا اماره
وعلامه على تساوي الليل مع النهار
ويعرفونها ايضا بالسلوك الحشري فاذا طلع
ابا دار بين قوسين الجعلان قالوا اذا طلع
ابا ذر تساوى الليل مع النهار
[موسيقى]
ختام الرابع بابرز عناوينها
مجموعه العمل الخليجيه الامريكيه تطالب
ايران وقف استفزازاتها النوويه وتدين
ممارساتها في المنطقه
رئيس فريق التدخل السريع بمركز الملك
سلمان يكشفوا للعربيه عن وصول خمسه الاف
خيمه لاواء متضرر الزلزال
ولي العهد السعودي يطلق شركه المربع
الجديد لتطوير اكبر داون تاون حديث عالميا
في الرياض
الفريق الطبي بمدينه الملك عبد العزيز
بالرياض ينتهي من عمليه فصل توام السيس
السيامي اليمني
شكرا لكم نهايه الرابعة